هنا في مصر كان هناك دائمًا
خيط ذهبي يمر عبر هذه
البلاد، لقد
سمح لهذه الرئتين بالازدهار
والنمو،
بالطبع
الممر المائي للفراعنة
هو نهر النيل الذي
ضاع في التفكير متسائلاً كيف كان سيكون
في الماضي مع  تذكير
بأنه ربما
لم تختف طرق الماضي تمامًا
[موسيقى]
كنت أفكر فقط أنها ليست
طرقًا أفضل بكثير للاستمتاع بوجبة الإفطار
على شروق الشمس في النيل والإبحار
الهادئ والهادئ
على النيل الأصفر
وهو قارب الحبايا التقليدي
يسمح لي بأخذ كل هذا في الاعتبار
لإبطاء العقل إلى حيث يصبح كل هذا منطقيًا، حيث
يتدفق النيل من الجنوب إلى الشمال بشكل غير
بديهي، فهو في الواقع يسير
عكس ما تعتقد أنه يحدث، لذلك
نحن نصعد نهر النيل على الرغم من
أننا حرفيًا  السفر عبر
البلاد ويسمون هذا الجزء من مصر
صعيد مصر لأنه أرض مرتفعة ولكنه في
الواقع أقل على الخريطة، لذلك نحن
نصعد نهر النيل إلى صعيد مصر على الرغم من أننا
نتجه جنوبًا
إلى الجزء السفلي من البلاد.
الموسيقى]
إنها من السفر الحديث السريع اليوم حيث
نعبر الكرة الأرضية في ساعات
هنا على نهر النيل، يمكن لروحي اللحاق
بحضوري الجسدي
أوه،
شكرًا جزيلاً لك، شكرًا لك يا
حب منتي،
أذكر النيل وبالطبع
أريد أن أكون جزءًا منه على الفور
موت أجاثا كريستي على نهر النيل
يجب أن أقبله لكوني عاملًا
أجنبيًا
شكرًا لك